so this whole thing has been about
making sure the consumer gets the signal
it's not about making a couple of guys
rich in the middle of it so when we come
a completely different technology and a
technology based in the routes of
broadcasting an antenna none of them can
dispute the facts because unfortunately
in this case they don't have a way to
dispute facts because the technology
works the way it did so there is all
this concoction and basically false
narratives being created that somehow
this is a copyright problem it's not the
problem is it's a business model problem
the world is changing around these guys
and they are reacting with what they
know which is litigate and kill in new
companies that come in because they're
making far too much money and continue
to make far too much money and have no
incentive to change the check can you
understand though that they are spending
CBS ABC FOX NBC spending millions
millions of dollars in programming that
basically you are charging people $8 a
month to access can you see though that
you that what they see what you're
talking about
as innovation they're saying is theft so
so here's sort of the issue right if if
we don't apply this technology to a
cable channel like HBO over up there is
a reason they are called free to air
broadcast television the essential
bargain with the computer consumer and
Congress is they program in Public
Interest convenience and necessity free
to the consumer they make money billions
and billions with advertising 90 plus
percent that bargain is preserved 60
million people in America today
according to the National Association of
Broadcasters uses an antenna are those
people infringing on their copyrights no
they're not tons of companies make money
selling equipment and technology TiVo
every antenna manufacturer out there all
these companies making money by selling
to you but you're more than just an
equipment provider even if that
equipment is in the cloud you do want to
be more than that the question is what
are we on a factual
and again but let's take check you get
into original programming let's say you
start developing your own channels
doesn't that change who you are no I
think a TiVo is a great example and I
point this out you can get a retail TiVo
box you can plug an antenna into it and
in fact Tebow will sell you video
on-demand movies from the internet side
by side where is this copyright
infringement it's only copyright
infringement because I've located the
Box remotely and I made it simpler for
the consumer to get it